what's up reject nation so if you guys
didn't catch our mandalorian season
finale reaction it is up on youtube
thank you to everyone who has watched it
so
far now within that finale there was a
moment
where luke skywalker was revealed and
you see his face
now if you watch our review we were part
of the camp
that was very clear on saying that while
we did noticed
flaws with the cgi especially with the
dead eyes and such
we were so wrapped up in the moment the
emotional
context of it that it almost didn't
matter yeah at the time then the debate
arose of
should they have done a deep fake or
should they have just stuck with
you know what we ended up getting with
that in mind from the channel strider hd
the mandalorian season finale deep fake
versus original
let's see which one looks better
wait a minute i couldn't even tell the
time i didn't read the text
are you a jedi i
[Music]
not sure which one to go with he wants
your permission
talent without training your head i will
give my life to protect the child
will not be safe until he masters his
abilities
it's weird parts that look better and
there are parts that don't look better
it looks at least a bit clearer the eyes
look better on the deep fake for sure
[Music]
all right it looks way better on the
deep fake there may the force be with
you
i'd say overall the deep fake one yeah
it just gives it more clarity it gives
it more
there's almost something at least side
by side fuzzy about what they went with
or
gauzed out maybe they had to blur the
footage a bit i don't know i mean in the
in the moment it was just so damn good i
yeah that
it didn't really bother me there are i
know a lot of people
who you hear all time from people who
who saw this moment did reactions or did
reviews
who have said that when that moment
occurred
it actually pulled them out of the
episode
that it deterred from it where i think
for a lot of us we were like no that was
cool
but there are a lot of people who were
like ooh
no no no i'm not even sucked into the
episode anymore
but it does make me wonder especially
for such a short-lived moment like this
why not just go with the deep fake i
could see for something like rogue one
why they took that approach
although i don't really know why i don't
really see why
studios don't want to do deep fakes yeah
when they look
better to me a lot of time versus cgi
face even for like
the irishman for example the deep fake
of that looked better than what we got
of robert de niro in the actual movie
and then here i'm like it's such a short
moment you might as well deep fake it
yeah i'd be really curious to hear what
their technology was for doing that and
how they arrived at that decision
because by now it cannot be
that much of a mystery to them that
people are making these comparisons
all the time and taking footage on a fan
level and making things that do
sometimes look
even if not yeah perfect like this
doesn't necessarily look perfect but it
does look
a bit better in some ways the count at
least in the eyes a little bit you know
and considering how that performance
there he's not really
a motive with his face he's not really
expressive you know
he's just very straightforward and it's
all about the eyes and that performance
he's had a very straightforward jedi
zen delivery very serious face and it's
all in the eyes
i don't know if you're like missing
performance there or not
but to me i should have gone with the
deep fake but that being said
i really want to make it clear it wasn't
that big of a deal with me
i noticed it and i was sitting there
going oh come on guys i'm rooting for
you i want this effect to look good
especially because it's only for like a
few seconds out of the entire episode
yeah but yeah i mean in context the
scene still plays
for me i don't know which one do you
guys think looks better the deep fake or
the original
and then knowing the way disney plus
actually is i think they did this for
something with mandalorian season one
already they definitely added the
mcclunky thing
what i'm saying is is that they can go
back at any
point in time and then change it if they
want if the effects do get better since
this was such a big debated thing
i'm sure they're working on making it
better so they could go back eventually
and redo it
that'll be the good application of those
george lucas instincts
to make all these dead eyes look liver
we'll see guys we'll see well which one
do you think looks better leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that notification bell check out
our mando reaction we'll catch you guys
soon